c'est l'un des plus grands golf d'île de
france avec ses 36 trous le golf blue
green de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aspire à être un des ponts vers d'un
secteur très urbanisé peut effectivement
voir après une semaine de
d'aération on voit les petites roues ya
quatre centres ou aux médias comme 13
autres de la franchise bluegreen le golf
a obtenu le symbolique label bronze pour
ses actions écologiques derrière moi on
peut effectivement voir des zones de ce
qu'on appelle deux aux rough qui sont
des zones donc du coup non tondue qui en
font partie effectivement c'est un
dossier qu'on remplit et on met en avant
toutes les actions qu'on fait pour être
dans ce label fauchage tardif
réduction des phytosanitaires emploi de
méthodes alternatives
réduction des hauteur de tonte pour
réduire la consommation d'eau tout ce
qui va être finalement enclin à
améliorer non pas notre bilan carbone
mais notre impact sur la nature en tout
cas là même la minimiser au maximum et
essayer de faire des choses bien des
étapes supérieures sont accessibles dans
le futur les labels argent puis or qui
récompense un travail encore plus
concret pour l'environnement le label
rond c'est le tout premier label qui dit
en gros que on est conscient des
bienfaits de l'écologie et par des
actions assez simple que d'ailleurs
beaucoup de golf met en place en tout
cas chez blue green
on arrive à accéder à ce premier ce
premier stade c'est extrêmement
important déjà parce que l'image du golf
souvent est assez assez négative ce qui
est comme nous le disait tout à l'heure
notre curgéens pitkowski une mauvaise
image et qui n'est pas juste parce qu'un
golf c'est effectivement un poumon vert
dès le 1er avril le golf sera enclin à
faire découvrir gratuitement ces
parcours aux visiteurs pour une longue
période de portes ouvertes jusqu'à la mi
mai